kimmig im abseits nein findet
ausgerechnet stiko chef merkens
josua ist experte für fußball nicht für
epidemien aber sein fall spricht
bedenken der leute an
boris palmer bürgermeister von thüringen
bei uns heute in berlin julia nagelsmann
der trainer von bayern münchen in
quarantäne obwohl doppelt geimpft und
joshua kimmig wahrscheinlich gesund aber
nicht geimpft erntet jetzt so ein mehr
an kritik ist es eine schräge diskussion
in ihren augen jetzt bin ich kein
fußballexperte aber ich habe einige
erfahrung mit stroms und ich finde wir
geraten in dieser gesellschaft so leicht
in erregung da hat einer was gesagt was
empirisch falsch ist die bedenken der
hat halte ich für falsch die kann man
sagt ich wieder legen und sagen so
stimmig da haben sie einfach nicht recht
und dann wäre für mich die debatte zu
ende und alles andere was dann noch
obendrauf gepackt wird das ist diese
erregungs und empörung demokratie die
finde ich nichts besser macht peter
tschentscher ist bei uns erst der
bürgermeister der schönen stadt hamburg
tschentscher politiker die sich nicht
impfen lassen sportler die nicht sich
nicht impfen lassen können die dann kein
vorbild mehr sein in diesem punkt
sichern ist aber natürlich ist ein sehr
guter fußballspieler das macht ihn aber
nicht zum experten und deswegen ist das
eine ganz persönliche auffassung der da
vertritt ich finde man sollte jetzt
einmal sehen dass wir ja von den
erwachsenen die jetzt seit anfang des
jahres geimpft werden können haben wir
in hamburg 86 prozent der erwachsenen
der über 18-jährigen jetzt geimpft das
ist schon eine sehr sehr große mehrheit
und deswegen glaube ich sollte mir nicht
so viel über diejenigen sprechen die
sich noch nicht haben impfen lassen
sondern überzeugen dass das gute idee
ist damit wir eben möglichst viele jetzt
noch gewinnen von diesen 14 prozent und
dennoch ist ja die frage sind das
persönlichkeiten die sozusagen nicht
rational urteilen die also gleichzeitig
auch wenn man so will eine
gesellschaftliche zensur bekommen dafür
dass sie sich anders entscheiden nein
ich finde man sollte klar sagen also er
hat die befürchtung dass es spätfolgen
gegen die ihm sorgen machen das kann ich
mir vorstellen dass viele auch so denken
aber es gibt eben genug experten die
auch erklären können dass das eine sehr
sehr
unrealistische erwartungen ist sondern
dass wir nach allem was ich einen
vielfachen millionenfachen einsatz des
impfstoffs aus sicht der besten
expertinnen und experten sagen können
das ist eine sehr sichere sache das ist
jedenfalls sehr viel sicherer sich
impfen zu lassen als mit diesem virus in
kontakt zu kommen wir haben alena büchs
bei und sie ist die vorsitzende des
deutschen ethikrates verbirgt wenn es
keinen rechtlichen impfzwang gibt in
diesem land und das halten wir uns ja
sehr zugute kann es dann einen
moralischen impfzwang geben also einen
moralischen impfzwang sicher nicht aber
wir haben schon formuliert dass es eine
moralische verpflichtung gibt weil man
nicht nur sich selbst schützt sondern
auch andere mit schützt und alle die
sich impfen lassen ja einen beitrag
leisten dass für uns alle diese pandemie
vorbei geht und das ist sozusagen ein
akt auch der solidarität nicht nur des
eigenen schutzes deswegen würden wir
sagen es gibt so eine art moralischer
impfpflicht aber die kann man natürlich
jetzt nicht gleichsetzen mit einer
rechtlich sanktion ehrbaren und wer sich
nicht impfen lässt der hat dann also
nicht einfach eine andere einstellung
sondern der hat sich schlecht informiert
und ist einfach dumm
das folgt daraus sicher nicht es gibt ja
das weiß man sehr viele unterschiedliche
gründe warum menschen sich nicht impfen
lassen das reicht von verwirrung über
tatsächlich falsch und fehlinformation
bis hin allerdings auch zu richtigen
überzeugungen die zum teil auch
ideologisch geprägt sind und man würde
natürlich nie so ein pauschalurteil über
all diese menschen fällen sondern immer
sagen man muss versuchen das zu
verstehen man muss versuchen die leute
da abzuholen wo sie sind und möglichst
zu überzeugen dass sie doch sich noch
den letzten ruck geben manche können
sich auch nicht impfen lassen auch dass
sich nochmal erwähnt johannes b kerner
ist bei uns in dieser sendungen und zwar
aus hamburg zugeschaltet bekannter sport
moderator und reporter der fall joshua
kimmig johannes b kerner ist für einen
sportmoderator warum besonders
bemerkenswert naja vielleicht kann man
das ein bisschen relativieren und es ist
ja in der sendung auch schon relativiert
worden der 50 pigs gestern in
mönchengladbach ist auf jeden fall
schmerzhafte
wie yoga kimmig über sich ergehen lässt
oder eben nicht ergehen lässt er hat
sich in der argumentation mit den
langzeitfolgen einfach vergaloppiert das
ist ja eben auch schon gesagt wurden vom
ersten bürgermeister der auch mediziner
ist dass es diese langzeitfolgen nach
einschätzung aller fachleute und nach
mittlerweile ich glaube 7 milliarden
verkauften rosen in der ganzen welt
nicht oder nur in einem wirklich
verschwindend geringen maße gibt da hat
er einfach falsch argumentiert und das
bedauerliche was damit einhergeht ist
dass er mit dieser argumentation denen
menschen dem dem kleinen aber ziemlich
umtriebigen quer denkenden teil in der
bevölkerung argumentativ vorschub
leistet die sagen jetzt mal selbst
joshua kimmig der hat bestimmt ganz
tolle informationen lässt selbst der
lässt sich nicht impfen und ich glaube
das tut er unfreiwillig aber das ist
eine unerwünschte nebenwirkung seiner
impf ablehnung und diese internationale
ja sehr wichtige impfkampagne kovacs zu
unterstützen einerseits und sich
andererseits also mit helfen zu wollen
das in aller welt dieser impfstoff
erhältlich ist für die menschen und sich
andererseits aber selber nicht zu impfen
das hat er sich auch noch nicht überlegt
oder also sagen wir so boris palmer hat
ja gesagt da ist ziemlich viel fahrt in
der debatte und ich gehöre nicht zu
denen die jetzt user kimmig einen
herausragenden fußballer am nasenring
durch die arena ziehen weil er einfach
einen fehler gemacht hat er hat einfach
falsch argumentiert ich denke dass er
nicht richtig informiert ist und das
muss sich ändern es wundert mich auch
ein bisschen dass gerade so ein donner
leistungssportler ganz offensichtlich in
diesem wichtigen teil seines
persönlichen lebens nicht richtig
informiert ist man muss sich vorstellen
er hat einen trainer der hatten taktik
trainern athletiktrainer
konditionstrainer physiotherapeut der
hat ein orthopädie schuhmachermeister
der ihm die einlage in die schule macht
der geht zur fußpflege und zum zahnarzt
also der lässt sich wirklich mit seinem
körper alles machen aber leider weil er
weiß das ist sein kapital aber an dieser
entscheidenden stelle ist er
offensichtlich von den ärzten dies ja
sowohl bei fc bayern münchen und zwar
gute als auch beim deutschen
fußball-bund ausreichend gibt und geben
sollte nicht gut informiert das muss
sich ändern für den unwahrscheinlichen
fall dass sie ihn in diese richtung
beraten haben wir ein viel größeres
problem ja das stimmt wir würden
unbedingt noch wissen wollen philipp
lahm hat sich geäußert jürgen klopp hat
sich geäußert das war interessant
die haben ja sehr rational argumentiert
jürgen klopp sagt irgendwie sich nicht
impfen zu lassen ist wie betrunken auto
zu fahren aber dieses argument auch des
mannschafts sportes und dass man dann
als leistungssportler für seine
mannschaft auch ausfallen kann wenn man
sich infiziert spielt das eigentlich
keine rolle also es gibt ja es auch
clubs wo man einfach kein geld bekommen
wenn man nicht spielt weil man infiziert
ist ich wünschte es würde eine rolle
spielen weil ich finde dass die
gemeinschaft da richtig entscheiden kann
wenn das in den mannschaften im
profifußball genauso wie im
amateurfußball und in anderen sportarten
auch diskutiert werden würde glaube ich
dass die kraft der argumente irgendwann
siegt und sich noch mehr menschen impfen
lassen würden und dann eben auch
vorbildlich handeln würden im sinne der
ganzen gesellschaft wenn ich eins noch
sagen da zu ihm als sportler was seine
individuelle entscheidungen angeht die
ist ja auch noch falsch weil er als
sportler wenn er höchstleistung bringen
und sein körper massiv beansprucht ist
ja für das virus 1 1 open window sagen
die mediziner glaube ich er läuft also
gefahr dass er einen besonders schweren
verlauf hat und selbst dramatisch leidet
unter dem virus also ist auch ganz
individuell die falsche entscheidung
aber das werden ihm leute sagen die
davon deutlich mehr verstehen als ich
und wenn sie es bisher noch im ausland
nicht ausreichendem maße getan haben
dann wird sich das vielleicht ändern wir
diskutieren das unbedingt und gleich
weiter und begrüßen sehr herzlich
sibylle katzenstein hausärztin in
berlin-neukölln schwerpunkt praxis nicht
zum ersten mal hier bei uns in der
sendung frau dr katzenstein elton
zweifel an der sicherheit von
impfstoffen die begegnen ihnen in ihrer
praxis wie oft und wie gehen sie damit
um also ich hab jetzt um die 6000
menschen geimpft und die
impfbereitschaft hat nicht wirklich
nachgelassen also gestern waren es über
100 und ich glaube das liegt vielleicht
gerade daran dass ich nicht die
moralische keule schwinge und ich habe
keinen einzigen patienten gehabt der
sich nun zur impfung bewegen dies weil
ein herr spahn sich als vorbild
impfen lässt oder weil ein herr kimmig
sich nicht impfen lässt also diese
diskussion hat es noch nie in meiner
praxis gegeben also es gibt wirklich
natürlich ein potpourri an verschiedenen
gründen warum leute jetzt sich erst
impfen oder sich vielleicht noch gar
nicht impfen lassen wollen aber das sind
wirklich sehr individuelle
entscheidungen und ängste spielen eine
große rolle sie glauben diese vorbilder
spielen eben weniger eine rolle also aus
meiner sicht überhaupt nicht also das
wäre leicht ihres handelns lesen werden
natürlich ist es der mensch zu mensch
kontakt ist es auch nicht alles immer
ganz rational und ich muss auch selber
sagen als ich im april mich habe impfen
lassen bin ich auch mit einer gewissen
aufregungen dahin gegangen da in zu
diesem zeitpunkt wäre es vielleicht
interessant gewesen wenn ein politiker
sich öffentlich im verlassen hätte aber
da war man ja dann moralisch verflucht
wenn man sich zu früh geübt hätte es hat
sich auch niemand getraut ging also ich
finde diese dieses ganze moral gewöhnt
sind das muss ein bisschen raus aus
dieser diskussion und es wird eben nicht
es hilft nicht er ist überzeugt
niemanden und wenn man ängste hat dann
möchte man vertrauensverhältnis und
möchte eigentlich auch äußern können was
für ängste man hat und vielleicht können
wir sogar für eine reform haben kim ich
etwas lernen nämlich ich glaube dass er
vielen menschen aus der seele spricht
also es sind bedenken über
langzeitfolgen und genau das was er eben
auch gesagt wurde von den menschen hier
auf der straße ich finde zum impfen
gehört erst mal die neugierde dem
gegenüber was sind denn deine motive
sich impfen oder nicht impfen zu lassen
und dann kann ich erst in die diskussion
einsteigen jonas schmidt chanasit ist
bei uns von der uni hamburg
schmidt-chanasit auch nicht zum ersten
mal in der sendung langzeit wirkungen
und nebenwirkungen des eine haben wir
schon gehört die nebenwirkungen gehören
und können natürlich zu der impfung
gehören langzeitwirkungen eher selten
wie kann man das durcheinander bringen
kann man es durcheinander bringen
man sollte es sozusagen als arzt
natürlich nicht durcheinanderbringen und
ich möchte ich noch mal zwei punkte
wenig besonders kritisch finden jetzt in
dieser diskussion sie sind auch schon
angesprochen worden zum einen ist
sozusagen die impfberatung eine
ärztliche tätigkeit um in den letzten
tagen sozusagen eine vielfalt vielzahl
von fachfremden meinungen gehabt was
jetzt sozusagen herr kimmig zu tun hat
oder nicht zu tun hat dass rock hudson
schein angesprochen hat das
vertrauensvolle persönliche gespräch mit
den menschen niemand impfen will und ich
habe das jahrelang auch als impf arzt
gemacht tausende menschen geimpft darauf
kommt es an dass man empathie zeigt und
auf die ängste eingeht und natürlich
dann mit den wissenschaftlichen fakten
argumentieren kann die eben ganz klar
eben für diese impfung sprechen und dann
muss man aber eben auch akzeptieren und
das musste ich auch in meiner zeit als
arzt dass es trotzdem menschen geben
wird die sich eben nicht impfen lassen
und dann muss man eben versuchen mit den
möglichkeiten die man über die impfung
hinaus hat natürlich zu arbeiten das
betrifft die malaria-prophylaxe wenn die
menschen die themen wollen was kann ich
denn machen was mache ich wenn ich mich
nicht gegen gelbfieber impfen lasse und
bei dieser impfung hat man die
möglichkeit sich zum beispiel regelmäßig
testen zu lassen und somit auch eine
zusätzliche sicherheit gegenüber den
kontaktpersonen zu ermöglichen und
joshua kimmig gemacht er hat sich ja
zweimal hatte zwei tage mit der pca
testen lassen und das gibt natürlich
eine zusätzliche sicherheit sagen sie
doch dennoch noch mal herr schmidt
chanasit
nebenwirkungen kann man natürlich haben
die sind in der regel aber kurz nach der
impfung im körper und erfolgen aber
langzeitwirkungen schon mal deshalb gar
nicht weil der impfstoff dann längst den
körper wieder verlassen hat das ist
richtig wie gesagt seltene
nebenwirkungen die eben am anfang nicht
entdeckt werden wenn sich sehr wenige
menschen haben impfen lassen die können
natürlich dann später entdeckt werden
wenn sich mehr menschen impfen lassen
haben aber sie haben jetzt gehört das
haben sich mehrere milliarden menschen
impfen lassen das heißt auch seltenste
nebenwirkung sind bekannt und das was
wir zum beispiel anderen impfstoffen
kennen was oftmals auch als beispiel
gebracht wird zb bei der dengue virus
impfung eine sogenannte antikörper
verstärken der reaktion die ist der
initial gesetzt worden nur die infektion
hatten später stattgefunden durchbruchs
infektion und damit auch die verstärkung
dieser durchbruchs infektion das ist
etwas was wir wissen und wir kennen wie
gesagt viele der wichtigen
nebenwirkungen die auch in einem
persönlichen vertraulichen gespräch
besprochen werden das heißt wie das
risiko für eine herzmuskelentzündung 7
thrombose alles bekannt und genau das
gehört aber wie gesagt ein persönliches
gespräch ist eine
private entscheidung und ich finde es
eben problematisch dass in der
öffentlichkeit so auszukehren und der
zweite punkt ist diese diskussion bringt
uns ja eigentlich vom eigentlichen thema
auch vollkommen ab es ist sicherlich
nicht problematisch sozusagen wenn sich
ein ja sehr gesunder fußballer nicht
impfen lässt sondern das problem sind
die über 60-jährigen dass wir dort mit
der booster impfung vorankommen müssen
dass wir dort auch noch einen bestimmten
anteil noch gar nicht erreicht haben das
ist doch worum es jetzt in den nächsten
wochen und monaten ganz entscheidend
diese diskussion bringt uns ja einfach
auf dem falschen weg wie werden über
booster noch reden das habe ich schon
vorneweg gesagt und dennoch ist
vielleicht ganz schlau diese bedenken
noch mal an den stellen nachzufragen wo
man sie selber verstehen möchte johannes
die frage es gibt auch spitzensportler
die schwere verläufe hatten und darüber
dann auch nachträglich erzählt hat
gelogen war so ein ilkay gündogan war so
ein fall bei den meisten fußballern die
sind relativ schnell durch damit ist das
auch ein grund dafür warum
[Musik]
leistungssportler im fußball sich nicht
so viel damit befassen also eigentlich
sollen sie zu 90 prozent geimpft sein
aber dafür gibt es nun wieder relativ
der fälle auf dem platz ja also sport
lassen wir auch menschen und haben
diesen und jenen verlauf und es gibt
schwere und leichte verläufe und die
meisten geimpften klagen überhaupt keine
nebenwirkungen ich habe heute
telefoniert mit einem arzt in hamburg
der circa 200 olympia reisende vor tokio
geimpft hat mit dem johnson johnson
impfstoff und der berichtet hat und
sagen alles leute aus allen
norddeutschen bundesländern und der
berichtet hat dass es einen einzigen
fall von nebenwirkungen gegeben hat aber
gab es einen hockeyspieler wohl der ein
paar tage lang leicht fiebrig war das
war das einzig möchte noch einen anderen
punkt wenn du mir das gestattet noch ne
wir wenn wir nur auf die zahlen kommen
nicht um himmels willen nicht in die
situation kommen dass ich irgendwas
medizinisch das sage dazu bin ich nicht
berufen das ist auch nicht meine
ausbildung aber wenn man sich die zahlen
anguckt und jetzt gerade davon spricht
dass wir in der mitten in der vierten
welle sind und dass das
gesundheitssystem wieder stärker
belastet ist dann sind doch heute die
meldung dass die die
die auslastung der intensivbetten
deshalb so dramatisch weil da
überwiegend fast ausschließlich
ungeimpfte liegen und das muss doch
jeder der noch nicht geimpft ist sich
vergegenwärtigen die möglichkeit dort
nicht hin zu müssen ist eine impfung und
und das hat nichts mit moral und nichts
mit vorbildwirkung eines
nationalspielers zu tun ist eine ganz
rationale entscheidung das man nutzen
und risiko abdeckt wenn ich keinen
schweren verlauf haben will das sagen
die fachleute dann lasse ich mich besser
impfen dann ist die chance dass ich mit
dieser erkrankung auf der
intensivstation lande geringer als ohne
info nun verhalten sich die menschen
nicht immer rational und boris palmer
das war interessant zu lesen ein
soziologe sieht bei rund der hälfte der
impfgegner keine medizinischen bedenken
sondern politische sie wollen damit
einfach protestieren das ist eine studie
von berthold vogel uni göttingen rund
die hälfte sind politisch motiviert aus
reinem protest skeptiker lassen sich
dann aus einem protest nicht impfen also
die menschen gibt es ganz ohne zweifel
das ist eine trotzreaktion und
ehrlicherweise muss ich sagen an manchen
punkten verstehe ich das sogar weil ich
diesen verdeckten impfzwang selber nicht
gut findet also was bei uns jetzt auch
in baden württemberg wohl am nächste
woche noch deutlich verschärft in
zukunft mit 2g regelungen wo dann nicht
geimpft er einfach am gesellschaftlichen
leben nicht mehr teilnehmen können das
wird ja irgendwie doch als zwang zur
impfung wahrgenommen von den leuten und
da wäre es ehrlicher zu sagen wie bei
der masern schutzimpfung entweder haben
wir den impfzwang das gilt ja für alle
und dann wissen wir bescheid
oder halt zu sagen nee wir haben keinen
impfzwang und dann wird auch nicht über
die hintertür versucht druck auszuüben
so dieses druck ausüben erzeugt
gegendruck das ist glaube ich eine
konstante das haben sie auch geschildert
dass menschen auf druck mit gegendruck
reagieren besonders dann wenn sie aus
irgendwelchen gründen vielleicht der
politik misstrauen oder da impfungen
misstrauen also schon vor geprägt sind
und deswegen hat nicht mitmachen wollen
deswegen halte es für unklug und bei der
sachlichen ebene finde ich sollte man
schon auch noch eins zugute halten er
hat ja nicht völlig frei von einer
tatsache gesprochen hat darauf
hingewiesen dass es tot impfstoffe schon
lange gibt und die abrupten der hätte
gerne tod impfstoff der also eine alte
produktklasse wo er meint da gibt es
kein risiko auf die lange sicht weil die
neue produktklasse die ja unter anderem
in tübingen entwickelt wurde
logischerweise keine langzeitstudien
haben können wir die gibt es erst seit
einem jahr im einsatz man kann nicht
wissen was in fünf jahren ist lässt sich
nicht beweisen sie haben sich selber
verkauf zur verfügung
da hatte ich habe zu dem politiker
gehören die ganz am anfang gesagt haben
ich mache sogar bei der studie mit weil
ich so wichtig finde dass wir diese
neuen wirkstoffe bekommen bei dieser
sehen aber platziert aber es ist ein
interessanter punkt ginger sie sind auch
arzt und
natürlich mit viel ahnung ausgestattet
in diesem bereich den tod im stoff der
in asien der in china verschifft wurde
millionenfach den lassen wir in der eu
nicht zu der könnte menschen die sagen
ich möchte lieber was jahrzehnte
erprobtes in meinen körper lassen als
einen frisch entwickelten impfstoff
vielleicht auch überzeugen der der neue
ergaben stadt ist ja auch nichts leben
dass das ist ein ra sind ehrenamtliche
keine kompletten viren also wenn man es
genau nimmt gibt es verschiedene
impfstoffe der zeit sie haben noch nicht
diesen klassischen antiken basierten
impfstoff den es in vielen anderen
zusammenhängen gibt der dann nur aus
einer proteinstruktur besteht
zulassung in europa bedeutet immer dass
man die studien kennt das man die die
daten kennt die den impfstoff als sicher
und wirksam darstellt dann würde das
auch in europa in deutschland zugelassen
werden aber ich finde bei dieser umfrage
ist es noch ein kleiner unterschied in
diesem fall als in vielen anderen fällen
wenn ich mich bin herr schmidt chanasit
sagt malaria prophylaxe ist zu empfehlen
wenn man es macht dann ist man geschützt
von malawi wir uns nicht macht wird man
krank ist aber etwas was in den
auswirkungen nur einen selbst betrifft
und in dieser corona pandemie und da
komme ich nochmal zu ihrer moralischen
verpflichtung entscheiden wir für uns
selber ein stück weit auch für die
gemeinschaft mit und wir würden jetzt in
einer ganz ganz schwierigen lage sein
wenn wir nicht diese hohen impfquoten
schon hätten also das können wir ja
sehen wie es in russland wie es in
anderen ländern ist wozu viele menschen
die entscheidung getroffen haben sich
nicht impfen zu lassen und deswegen ist
es schon auch einfach ein thema das ist
nicht nur um individuelle entscheidungen
wird also das bringt ja auch gleich dann
als nächstes frau birgt die frage auf es
hat für jeden ein impfangebot gegeben
jeder konnte sich informieren und wann
endet dann eigentlich die
fürsorgepflicht des staates man kann es
natürlich auch andersherum fragen und
dann würden sie sagen die
fürsorgepflicht des staates endet jetzt
also für diese geimpfte person die sich
frei entscheiden kann die das angebot
hat der kann man nicht ewig hinterher
laufen das ist völlig klar das ist eine
nach wie vor private freie entscheidung
und ich muss auch ein paar noch ein
bisschen widersprechen ich beginne um
pflicht also eine echte recht rechtlich
sanktion ihr wahre impfpflicht das ist
ein ganz harter eingriff in die
grundrechte und ich höre das argument
mit der ehrlichkeit aber natürlich sind
die maßnahmen vorher weniger starke
eingriffe in die grundrechte und das ist
nachvollziehbarer weise der grund
weshalb man nicht von dem ein sozusagen
ganz weit vor sprint und dann auf einmal
die impfpflicht einfach bloß weil
sozusagen ehrlicher wäre mit blick auf
die intention wir wollen möglichst viele
menschen geimpft haben da muss man diese
schritte schon alle durchgehen so jetzt
hat der staat nicht nur die
fürsorgepflicht für die person der ein
info angebot gemacht wird sondern ja
auch für alle anderen und da muss ich
wiederum herrn tschentscher sehr recht
geben ich weiß das klingt immer so nach
der moralkeule mit den verpflichtungen
aber kollegen haben gerade in österreich
ein schönes papier veröffentlicht das
den titel hat
eine pandemie ist keine privatsache und
das ist richtig denn wer sich jetzt im
moment nicht impfen lässt und das risiko
eingeht sich mit dieser sehr
ansteckenden delta variante zu
infizieren der geht auch das risiko ein
ins krankenhaus zu gehen und wenn wir
wie der und wir wissen leider regional
dass manche intensivmediziner heute hat
die deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft die
hand gehoben und idee wie das manche
krankenhäuser schon wieder ziemlich am
limit sind dann hat das einen effekt auf
ganz viele andere menschen wir hängen da
zusammen drin ob wir wollen oder nicht
dass das nicht wie frau katzenstein ganz
wichtig sagt binz individuelle
arzt-patienten-verhältnis gehört das ist
völlig klar aber wir sind alle bürger
dieser gesellschaft wir sind alle
menschen die das gesundheitssystem
brauchen wir haben kinder die vom baum
fallen können und ins krankenhaus müssen
wir können hier um die ecke mit dem auto
gegen den baum fahren und ein
krankenhausbett brauchen wir hängen da
zusammen ob wir das wollen oder nicht
und deswegen glaube ich fürchte ich
kriegt man dieses gemeinschaftliche da
nicht ganz raus dann ist es herr palmer
also doch nicht eine privatsache oder
nur bis zu einem bestimmten punkt und
wenn man dann ein intensiv bett bräuchte
betreffe es die allgemeinheit dass auch
sie eine frage ich habe mich ja auch
nicht für die impfpflicht ausgesprochen
aber gesagt wenn man eigentlich eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür haben
wollte dann sollte man es anders machen
ich bin aber nicht dafür ich bin der
meinung dass es mit anreizen und
überzeugung besser laufen wird als mit
druck ganz konkret wir haben in der
stadtverwaltung tübingen gesagt wer sich
impfen lässt bekommt eine stunde
arbeitszeit gut geschrieben und zwar
auch wenn es schon vor drei monaten
gewesen ist damit es nicht ungerecht
wird weil ich jetzt möchte dass die zehn
prozent die wir vielleicht noch haben
dass die sich in der arbeitszeit impfen
lassen könnten und ich verspreche mir
davon mehr als wenn ich jetzt den
verbietet beim weihnachtsmarkt glühwein
zu trinken das ist der gedanke ich würde
mehr mit überzeugung und mit anreizen
arbeit wir sind frau dr katzenstein ja
immer noch auf der suche nach den
menschen die es in allererster linie
ablehnen sich impfen zu lassen er wird
vom bildungsstatus gesprochen es wird
von sogenannten migrationshintergrund
gesprochen aber was wissen wir darüber
eigentlich wenn wir nicht mal richtig
präzise wissen wie viele menschen sich
überhaupt schon geimpft haben das kommt
ja noch dazu
also das war der grund warum ich von
anfang an nicht im impfzentrum impfen
wollte ich wollte meine eigenen
erfahrungen aufbauen und sowohl die
menschen vorher kennenlernen als auch
die nachsorge haben und das ist mir auch
gut gelungen weil ich impfe und die
leute kommen weiter zu mir ich glaube
was stark vernachlässigt worden ist ist
die interdisziplinäre zusammenarbeit
zwischen ärzten und sozialen trägern das
funktioniert bei mir hervorragend das
heißt ich habe schon vor einem jahr
kontakt aufgenommen mit sozialarbeitern
streetworkern habe die grippe impfung
erst mal angeboten und nach wie vor im
fisch auch über 60-jährige und wirklich
ein hoch gefährdetes klientel und dann
geht es ehrlich gesagt überhaupt gar
nicht um diese ganze diskussion die wir
hier führen das sind menschen man auch
nicht ausschließen kann aus der
gesellschaft die sind nämlich schon
ausgeschlossenen vieler hinsicht die
gehen nicht ins restaurant die gehe ich
ins fitnesscenter da können wir reden
was wir wollen die brauchen einfach
überhaupt einen kontakt wieder ins
gesundheitssystem die sind oft auch ganz
schön krank und empfinden sich gar nicht
so krank also wenn ich mit denen spreche
und frage haben sie vorerkrankungen höhe
und dann stellt sich eben raus naja
vielleicht schon zwei herzinfarkte und
die copd oder ist doch kommt irgendwie
nur eine kleine nebenerscheinung für
menschen die obdachlos sind für menschen
die langzeitarbeitslos sind
diese ganze diskussion interessiert die
gar nicht aber die möchte ich erreichen
also arbeite ich interdisziplinär weil
ohne sozialarbeiter und streetworker
hätte ich keine chance und diese
wirklich kosteneffizienten und
einfachen methoden die werden finde ich
völlig vernachlässigt verstehe ich nicht
also es wird geld reingepumpt in diese
impfkampagne
aber so ein bisschen einfach so an der
basis und wie rede ich mit den menschen
kommunikationstraining
respekt vor der meinung eines anderen ja
also ich ja sagt jedem patienten zu
können zur beratung kommen sie können
selbstverständlich auch ungeimpfte
wieder rausgehen und dann kommen sie
vielleicht nächste woche wieder oder
übernächste woche und das in china sieht
hat ja auch schon erwähnt dass das der
goldene weg aus seiner sicht ist mit den
menschen zu reden das argument zu hören
zu wägen und dann auch mit persönlichen
überzeugungen und eben einer echten
beratung unterwegs zu sein nun hat herr
tschentscher ausgerechnet der
bundesgesundheitsminister gesagt vier
von fünf erwachsenen seien schon geimpft
jens spahn findet das ist eine gute zahl
obwohl ich will dass einmal ganz kurz
noch mal sagen wir vom ärger ja
tatsächlich nicht zahlen bekommen denen
wir vertrauen können also der karl
lauterbach sagte dass sie sich
nennenswert und auch wissentlich mit
geschätzten zahlen zufrieden gegeben
haben weil sie einen teil der
betriebsärzte und auch der arztpraxen
befreien wollte von diesem riesigen
bürokratischen aufwand und eigentlich
wusste man seit juno dass auch unsere
geimpften zahlen nicht stimmen sondern
dass sie wahrscheinlich höher liegen
jetzt könnte man sich zurücklehnen und
könnte sagen das ist ja prima und dann
kommen die genesenen noch dazu und dann
eigentlich eine ganz gute situation dass
jens spahn sagt zu recht wir sind in
einer guten
situation und können deshalb auf diese
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
tatsächlich also die das erste teil ich
wir haben schon sehr viel erreicht ich
habe ihnen gesagt von den erwachsenen
über 18 jährigen sind es in hamburg 86
prozent und die die noch nicht geimpft
sind die sind auch sehr unterschiedliche
menschen sie haben beschrieben wie sie
ihren zugang finden zu einem teil der
ungeimpften wir haben auch gute
erfahrungen gemacht damit
niedrigschwellig in stadtteile zu gehen
in ein einkaufszentrum zu gehen ich habe
bis vor kurzem gehörte war auf dem kiez
kneipe da hat er wird das organisierte
gab es eine lange schlange die drei mal
am platz weil die leute dachten auch
hier bin ich ja sonst auch wenn hier
gilt nicht dabei also die impfstrategie
muss so verschieden sein wie die
menschen die wir erreichen wollen und
dann können wir noch mehr erreichen es
gibt eine kleine dunkelziffer von nicht
gemeldeten impfungen wie kann man
abschätzen aber wir sind jedenfalls in
hamburg bei mindestens 86 prozent bei
den erwachsenen das zweite ist eine
andere frage wir haben in dem im
vergangenen jahr oder in diesem jahr ja
die impfung vorangebracht und damit wenn
man so will einen deich wird wir haben
norden sorgen gegen die flut aufgebaut
und jetzt kommt die flut wir sind im
herbst jetzt kommt der saisonalen effekt
und wir sehen das ja auch die viren
haben sie da leichter und jetzt werden
wir in den nächsten wochen erfahren ob
der damm hält ich hoffe dass er hält ich
denke auch dass wir keine drastischen
maßnahmen mehr brauchen aber bevor wir
es genauer wissen wäre mir wohl dazu
sagen wir erhalten diese epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite noch bis
ende des jahres aufrecht
wenn man das nicht möchte das scheint ja
jetzt die politische mehrheit mann zu
sein muss man aber wenigstens
sicherstellen dass wir auf andere art
und weise die schutzkonzepte die wir
noch brauchen dass wir die rechtssicher
auch vor gericht
absichern kommen wir gleich noch dazu
interessant ist ja boris palmer hat
erwähnt baden württemberg geht einen
eigenen weg des saarland geben ganz
anderen weg da ist jetzt die absolute
freiheit ausgerufen
und es müssen nicht mal mehr masken
beispielsweise bei den fußballern und
dem publikum getragen werden und test
schon gar nicht also da ist wirklich
seit 29
die große freiheit nummer 9 im saarland
zu hause ist es noch nachvollziehbar für
sie glauben sie dass die menschen das
noch verstehen also ehrlicher weise ich
habe keinen überblick mehr wie jetzt die
regelungen in welchem bundesland grad
sind ich muss mich sehr bemühen die
meinem bundesland zu verstehen weil ich
sie ja auch umsetzen soll und sie werden
sich in den nächsten tagen wieder ändern
wir hatten als beispiel vor wenigen
tagen die erlaubnis mit 2g die masken
beim personal in gaststätten abzunehmen
und ab montag wird diese erlaubnis
wieder zurückgenommen werden weil die
zahlen steigender einlieferungen in die
krankenhäuser oder wir haben eine neue
regelung dass alle beschäftigten die
kontakt haben außenkontakt haben da gilt
auch schon eine andere abteilung als
außenkontakt dass die verpflichtet sind
sich zweimal die woche testen zu lassen
gleichzeitig darf der arbeitgeber aber
nicht wissen ob sie sich testen wie so
eine testpflicht dann funktionieren soll
finde ich schwer verständlich meiner
meinung nach da ist es nicht zu ende
gedacht und auch für die leute komisch
weil ich kann jetzt als
oberbürgermeister halt gerade nicht
garantieren dass die leute die hinter
dem tresen stehen entweder geimpft oder
getestet sind weil die nur selber wissen
ob sie getestet sind und ich den status
nicht auf fragen darf also wir sind
schon wieder in diesem bereich der
detailregelungen wo man dann als der
praktiker an der front sagt leute ich
das jetzt noch wirklich durchdacht und
angemessen oder kommen wir danach nicht
wieder ein ganz komische situation und
dann dieses saarbrücken und spielen und
im stadion irgendwie die fußballer nicht
nur auflaufen lassen sondern auch alle
menschen entscheidung könnten sie sich
also ich bin jetzt die oberliga und
auf der liga dabei haben keine gefahr
große fuß- oder bildet wird wie so was
merken
im freien glaube ich ist das vertretbar
ich würde gerne den punkt auch noch
machen es geht wenn sie sagen sie würden
die epidemische notlage gerne verlängern
hat wünsche ich ihm schnelle erklärung
darüber ich meine dass der bundestag
kann ich darüber entscheiden ob die
epidemische lage naja wie viel ist aber
genau das hat die regierung darüber
abgeben und eine annahme der bestellung
bei daran ändert sich ja nichts sondern
wir wissen ja das ist jetzt schon
belastete krankenhäuser wiedergibt
gerade in baden württemberg in bayern
thüringen sachsen sein und hat eine hohe
im
hör ich glaube auf platz zwei gegen die
im ranking das ist ein höherer da ich
sozusagen in der 63 wir sind
mittlerweile auf platz drei wir waren ja
das finde ich das nochmal reden und wir
haben nicht so viel impfstoff bekommen
zu anfang aber das zeigt ja dass wir mit
verschiedenen strategien wirklich den
besten schutz aufbauen ich hoffe wir
kommen durch sowie wir haben keine
großen schlimm maßnahmen ja keine
schulschließung keine lockt da uns keine
ausgangssperren aber wir müssen eben
sehen was in den nächsten wochen noch
passiert und ich bin nicht ganz sicher
ob bestimmte länder was thüringen und
sachsen vielleicht noch nötig ist die
nächsten wochen das kann ich nicht
vorhersagen kann niemand verwehren
deswegen werden wir da wohl denn
normalerweise
nicht wieder gefasst werden soll da
hatten sich die top- brauchen darf ich
den punkt noch mal machen so wie sie
haben sie haben den punkt vorher nicht
zu ende führen sie sagen sie hätten
würden gerne diesen beschluss erneuern
und ich finde er sollte jetzt wirklich
auslaufen sowie die koalitions verzogen
ist auch angekündigt haben warum weil
ich finde dass diese balance zwischen
freiheit und gesundheitsschutz gewahrt
werden muss und wenn es nicht mehr
absehbar ist dass wir schulschließungen
oder komplette lockt das brauchen das
ist einfach nicht absehbar dafür ist der
damm hoch genug denn sie zitiert und
aufgebaut haben durch die impfungen dann
finde ich dass es auch wichtig ist der
bevölkerung zu sagen das sind nicht
politiker am werk die wollen möglichst
den patriarchalen obrigkeitsstaat und
möglichst viele kompetenzen an sich
ziehen und uns irgendwie dauernd gegen
länder die geben uns diese freiheiten
auch wieder zurück und dafür halte ich
dieses beschlusses auslaufen zu lassen
und zu reduzieren auf niederschwellige
angriffe weil darum geht zu einem
wesentlichen die anderen maßnahmen
bleiben möglich halte ich für wichtig
und richtig den punkt sollte er noch
machen wiederwahl
da wurde der beste weg für mich wäre
jetzt bis ende des jahres soll es
einfach plausibel ist jetzt noch mal zu
testen ob wir wirklich sicher sind der
zweitbeste welches das was sie sagen es
ist nur rechts rechts unsicher wir
müssen ja damit rechnen dass wir vor
verwaltungsgerichten widerstehen und
dann sagt ein verwaltungsgericht der
bund hat doch erklärt die lage ist
entspannter der könnte jetzt nicht in
den gleichen maßnahmen weiter machen
wenn objektiv der bundestag festgestellt
hat dass die pandemische lage nicht mehr
so dramatisch ist für mich das momentan
ein schwieriger zeitpunkt ich verstehe
diese argumentation ist es ja auch
wirklich eine sehr schwierige
diskussionslage wurde behauptet wird man
hätte freiheiten genommen nein wir haben
in der verpflichtung das gemeinwesen zu
schützen wir haben ja eine verantwortung
in der politik haben wir maßnahmen
ergriffen um diese pandemie zu bekämpfen
das ist jetzt aktuell in keinem
bundesland mehr so dass da irgendwo
überzogene massen haben aber gleich nach
rein willkürlich wäre erfolgen und ich
sagte ja nur der sicherste weg wäre dass
bis ende des jahres sich noch anzusehen
aber
zweitbeste lösung ist dass die
bundestagsabgeordneten sehr genau das
gesetz so formulieren dass wir mit den
maßnahmen die wir auf jeden fall noch
brauchen vor gericht auch bestand und
eben nicht durch landesgerichte hier
noch ein wir haben das gelände durch
oberverwaltungsgerichte eine eigene
sicht auf diese fragen haben und dann
erfährt man plötzlich das ist als
mäßigkeit prüfung schützt sie gar nichts
die ausgangssperren waren halt nicht
verhältnismäßig das geht auch mit
epidemische notlage nicht es bleibt
immer zum glück war die gerichte die das
grün in hamburg vor gericht mehrfach
bestätigt worden ich bin aber nicht
dabei das mag sein weil jedes land hat
ja auch anders begründet und hat andere
lagen gehabt aber es ist schon wichtig
dass man die gerichte haben eine eigene
auch juristische logik die kann ich zum
teil sehr gut nachvollziehen und wenn
der bundestag jetzt sagt und wenn die
politik jetzt sagen wenn die risiken der
vergehen sollen die einnahmen der anlage
wir haben keine nationale tragweite mehr
dann hat das juristisch sicher folgen
ich bin jetzt nicht der oberste jurist
aber ich habe erlebt wie schwierig es
oft ist dann im einzelfall wirklich auch
dass das durchzustehen und wir sind
wirklich jetzt in den nächsten wochen in
einer sehr viel schwierigeren lage noch
mal als im letzten halben jahr weil die
saisonalen bedingungen und schwerer
machen und ich mache mir schon sorgen
über das was ich aus sachsen aus bayern
auch oskar wird höre dass dort wirklich
auch die intensivstation schnell der
fall sind man muss auch mal ans
pflegepersonal dort denkt machen wir
hier haben sich als erste impfen lassen
da war es noch sehr unsicher was alles
mit diesen impfungen im zusammenhang
steht weil sie für sich selber auch
angst hatten aber natürlich ihre
verpflichtungen auch noch gekommen sind
und dann zu sagen ich will mich nicht
impfen lassen ich will aber auch party
machen und ich finde es gibt keine
einschränkung aber wenn ich dann
erkranken dann muss mich das personal
was jetzt schon seit anderthalb jahren
anerkannte arbeitet mich auch nach
versorgen das auch ein gesichtspunkt den
ich allen zum nachdenken empfehle da ist
noch mal ein argument ich wollte die
johannes unbedingt noch fragen wie er im
märz/april des märz des letzten jahres
2020 hattest du dich infiziert johannes
und bis dann auch geimpft worden einmal
geimpft worden wie hast du dich beraten
lassen ehrlich gesagt von einem
befreundeten arzt also erstmal weiter
genießen da war aber noch alles unklar
im märz vergangenen jahres und dann als
ich sozusagen altersmäßig dann auch mal
in richtung an die reihe kam habe ich
mich von einem befreundeten arzt der mit
vielen sportlern auch zu tun hat beraten
lassen und dann immer gesagt dann machen
wir jetzt impfungen damit war ich ja
nach unseren verordnungen sozusagen
durchgeimpft also genesen und einmal
geimpft hatte anspruch auf diesen corona
free pass hat mich aber dann
mittlerweile ein zweites mal impfen
lassen weil ich das brauchte weil ich
meine tochter in kanada besucht habe und
kanada zwingend zwei pixel vorschreibt
und mit dem genesen dann nicht mitmacht
und deshalb bin ich also genesen und
zweimal gegen stunden
und du hast jetzt natürlich auch als
moderator und kommentator gesehen wie in
verschiedenen ländern sicherlich auch
dieses landes zwischen zuschauern und
regeln unterschieden wurde es gibt zwei
gs gibt 3g für die zuschauer es gibt
eben zuschauer die tatsächlichen nicht
ins stadion dürfen wie sehr ist das noch
nachvollziehbar für das publikum für das
publikum das hat zwei aspekte die möchte
ich gerne so beantworten das eine ist
wir wollen ja einmal keinen
flickenteppich der der föderalen
struktur geschuldet ist sozusagen hier
die regelung da die regelung nord süd
ost west aber tatsache ist ja auch und
und das hat dr tschentscher eben gesagt
wenn wir uns die instanzen angucken in
verschiedenen bundesländern wenn ich mir
allein die deutschlandkarte anguckt und
coco ist dunkelrot und wo es grau und
gelb dann ist es eben einen
flickenteppich und vielleicht erfordert
das im einzelfall auch unterschiedliche
maßnahmen ganz generell weil du das
ansprichst mit 2g und 3g also zum
beispiel nur mit 2g ins stadion als
zuschauer aber 3g da habe ich unten auf
dem platz spielen da kann ich nur sagen
das hat uns das potenzial die
gesellschaft zu spalten
kommen wir dann leicht auch in so eine
diskussion von die da oben und wir da
unten und ich bin der meinung alles was
das potenzial hat das gemeinwesen zu
spalten unsere gesellschaftliche
struktur auseinander zu bringen ist
schlecht dagegen hilft aufklärung sowie
die wunderbare frau katzenstein das
macht in ihrer mensch zu mensch
begegnung in der praxis in neukölln wenn
ich das im untertitel richtig gelesen
habe im großen hieße dass aufklärung
möglichst vielen menschen möglichst
viele informationen geben damit das
gemeinwesen eine überlebenschance habe
das ist am ende des tages auch in und
nach dieser pandemie das allerwichtigste
und es gibt natürlich auch eine menge
wut und eine menge protest von irgendwie
team vorsicht wir dürfen wir nicht team
weltfremd werden ist irgendwie noch die
netteste umschreibung wie würde wie
kommt man da jetzt durch den herbst und
durch den winter glaubst du und ja gut
ich bin ja nicht in ein amt gewählt und
muss irgendwas jetzt entscheiden
insofern bin ich in der luft zu kommen
bei den mannschaften direkt ja ich
glaube nach dem was ich jetzt gelesen
habe auch in der sogenannten kimmig
diskussion dass die bundesligavereine ja
doch eine klare haltung haben und ihren
spielern dass die impfung empfehlen und
das aber auch fußballer bürger sind und
insofern auch für die keine impfpflicht
besteht steht außer frage insofern haben
wir die situation dass auch dort weiter
aufgeklärt werden muss also ich kann nur
sagen die mannschaftsärzte des fc bayern
münchen sollten sich den kimmig morgen
früh schnappen und mit ihnen nochmal
ganz intensiv darüber reden was er dann
entscheidet das bleibt sein seine
persönliche sache aber sie sollten
intensiv mit ihm sprechen also dann ist
trotzdem die interessantere das wären
wir hier noch diskutieren und bedanken
uns ganz herzlich bei dir nach hamburg
ob die nicht genau so begründet sagen
könnten der bundesgesundheitsminister
hat er gesagt die lage wird immer besser
also wir haben wahrscheinlich auch einen
widersprüchlichen
meinungen ganz lieben dank gehören ist
dass sie heute hier bei uns was und
damit sind sie hierbei diese in diesem
ende diesem ausgerufenen ende einer
notlage frau box und sie sagen uns noch
mal was das jetzt eigentlich für eine
kommunikative katastrophe ist dass man
eigentlich immer noch für das impfen
werben möchte und dass man immer noch
weiß dass wir nicht genug geübt haben
und andererseits sagt
wir sind kurz vom freedom day oder
besser gesagt die menschen das so
verstehen das ist ein ganz wichtiger
nach lag also das ist wirklich eine
schwierige situation ich glaube man muss
noch mal eine sache unterstreichen bei
dieser aufhebung der lage die ja schon
relativ lange gefordert wird gibt es
auch so ein demokratiepolitisches
argument dass man einfach sagte jetzt
hat doch sehr lange der bund die
kompetenzen gehabt und es ist eben eine
situation nationaler tragweite also eine
nationale notlage und die liegt nach
einschätzung sehr viele
absehbar in der art und weise nicht mehr
vor deswegen ist das ansinnen zu sagen
wir regionalisieren das ganze und lassen
die länder flexibel reagieren auf die
situation die bei ihnen vorher an sich
nachvollziehbar
gleichzeitig unter gehe ich mit herrn
tschentscher völlig d'accord da haben
wir eine situation bei der man sehen
kann das raus jetzt wieder richtig ab
und da ist ein widerspruch also
staatsrechtlich ist das nachvollziehbar
aber für bürgerinnen und bürger klingt
das nach freedom day es ist kein freedom
day ganz klar nicht es soll wenn einem
freedom der am 20 märz geben also im
moment ist angedacht dass am 20 märz
dann wirklich alle maßnahmen enden das
finde ich durchaus sehr mutig an sich
das zutrauen aber natürlich wird ein
katalog von maßnahmen beibehalten werden
kommunikativ geht das nicht zusammen das
symbol ist die notlage ist vorbei und
nicht die nation also der die betonung
bei der aufhebung ist auf dem nationalen
aber für bürgerinnen und bürger ist das
glaube ich nicht auseinander zu
auseinanderzuhalten zwischen den
einzelnen ländern vielleicht glaubst du
schätzen die bürgerin bürger können die
gut auseinanderhalten das ist so eine
allgemeine politiker denkt jetzt einmal
politiker denken wir wissen wie wir sind
der gesellschaft mündiger bürger das ist
doch jetzt nicht so kompliziert sie
haben es doch toll erklärt das versteht
die leute verstehen die wenn er selber
sagt was wenn nicht das ist jetzt eine
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite und ich möchte als bayerischer
ministerpräsident dass die verlängert
wird und nicht aufgegeben wird und auf
der anderen seite eine andere politische
entscheidung gefällt wurde von einer
noch nicht im amt seinen den ampel aber
es eigentlich durch den
bundesgesundheitsminister auch das
signal gibt wir sind wirklich in einer
anderen situation und können nicht mehr
von einer nationalen not sprechen und
politischer streit wir haben die haare
sagen wir wissen dass ich immer schwer
zu verstehen politisch also das argument
von frau wuchs war ganz einfach zu
verstehen leute die notlage ist vorbei
aber sich immer noch ernst die stunde zu
schwierig das ist wahr aber man hat
gleichzeitig viele menschen die wirklich
angst haben also die in den landkreisen
leben in denen zb bei den kindern die
instanzen über 1000 liegen das ist das
fühlt sich sehr bedrohlich an der base
ich will niemandem unterstellen dass die
leute das nicht verstehen leute sind
sehr viele da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
also wenn das so rübergekommen ist dann
möchte ich das möchte ich mich
entschuldigen dann aber dass das
auseinanderfällt sozusagen in den
botschaften das äußern auch sehr viele
leute also das ist tatsächlich etwas was
relativ vehement im moment zum beispiel
in den sozialen medien vorgebracht wird
moment mal bei den kindern raus das
jetzt einfach durch da werden die masken
abgenommen im unterricht bei in sehr
sehr hohem inzidenz und auf der einen
seite und gleichzeitig ist aber doch
irgendwie schlimm also wir haben da
schon sehr viele widersprüchliche
botschaften und ich würde mir einfach
wünschen vielleicht sollte man so eher
formulieren vielleicht geht es gar nicht
darum wer was wie versteht sondern ich
würde mir wünschen dass so einfach wie
sie es gerade in diesen zwei sätzen
gesagt haben notlage ist vorbei es ist
aber immer noch wackelig das so
sozusagen kontinuierlich in die
kommunikation gegangen wäre vielleicht
jonas schmidt-chanasit noch mal jede
jede bundes entschuldigung jede
landesregierung findet jetzt ihre eigene
begründung und auch erst einmal ihr
eigenes maßnahmenpaket herr schmidt
chanasit würden sie sagen das ist völlig
in ordnung und das halten wir aus oder
ist es jetzt gerade im herbst winter
das falsche viele bürgermeister
tschentscher gesagt hat es die situation
in den bundesländern sehr
unterschiedlich angefangen von den
impfquoten und auch von den
möglichkeiten die zielgruppen zu
erreichen meines erachtens sind drei
punkte ganz entscheidend in diesem
herbst und winter ich hatte schon
angesprochen zum einen die booster die
auffrischimpfung so wie sie auch von der
stiko empfohlen sind das ist eine
gewaltige aufgabe die vor uns steht wir
diskutieren die ganze zeit über eine
relativ überschaubare gruppe die noch
eine grundimmunisierung braucht aber
meines erachtens eine große aufgabe die
auffrischimpfung jetzt durchzuführen zu
organisieren und das an einem relativ
kurzen zeitraum dass er mehr als 20
millionen menschen der zweite punkt ganz
entscheidend niedrigschwellige
testangebote für die menschen die
wirklich gefährdet sind ich spreche
nicht über test um einen supermarkt zu
betreten sondern für angehörige zum
beispiel die ältere menschen pflegen
ganz entscheidend weil wir eben sehen
dass es verstärkt zu ihm durch brüchen
kommen und 2g eine scheinsicherheit in
diesen bereichen
letztendlich suggeriert insofern sind
die tester hier ganz entscheidend um gut
durch den winter zu kommen aber
angemerkt qualitativ hochwertige teste
das muss gut kontrolliert sein zum teil
haben wir ja wirklich problematische
situation auch bei den testen gesehen
auch in hamburg wo dann letztendlich ja
auch die polizei zum beispiel auch tätig
geworden ist in der dritte punkt
wäre noch dass wir das was jetzt schon
angesprochen hat unbedingt natürlich auf
den pflegenotstand sehen die sind an
einer enormen belastung nicht erst seit
zwei jahren ausgesetzt sondern das ist
prinzipiell eine sehr schwierige
situation
und nun stellen sie sich mal vor wie
eine pflegekraft sozusagen bestimmte
hygiene-vorschriften standards einhalten
soll wenn sie eine vielzahl von älteren
patienten versorgen soll und das ist wie
gesagt nicht besser geworden in der
pandemie und das führt dann dazu dass
betten abgemeldet werden und dass es
eben natürlich auch zu ausbrüchen in
diesen einrichtungen kommt also das sind
meines erachtens die drei entscheidenden
punkte für diesen herbst und winter